so I got a PR box I'd love to make a
video series about the weird and
wonderful things you guys send so if
you'd like to get involved details in
the description and now two months after
I promised here is a psg room tour 2019
B want I'm a weird guy I really am
hope you enjoy so here is my room my is
a garage actually where I work is a
converted garage it's nothing too fancy
cool it's it's just where I work but
yeah there's a lot of crap in this room
so over the next ten minutes shall we
say I will attempt to explain this
madness so let's start with the desk I
suppose at the moment I use three
predator monitors so recently I've
changed how I put my monitors together
this is the coordination of it all and I
really like this stacked effect having
this extra monitor on the right is
pretty cool too attentive discard on
that so I work on the center monitor and
the one above is like youtube audio
editing things which aren't as important
as the middle screen and yeah I have a
thing for this artwork is oh we this is
I won't explain this it let's just
pretend that never happened okay on this
top screen here's where I do my audio
editing and just check on things like
that and yeah here we go here's my discs
are up and running now that's hey will
we get any respondents please focus
stupid-ass camera sniff fantastic oh
well this was this was a bad attempt
let's give them a second chance
focus wow wish the man hello Adam hello
Bonnie
hello Bob can't read that name Isabel hi
Adam hi Isabel I hope you watch this
video and see yourself okay yeah that's
my desk anyway so um I have some other
things like my ps4 ps4 Pro is the one I
use at the moment and I've started using
a scuf what the hell is going on with
the camera I've started using a scuf
controller I tested it about a year ago
if you remember I did a video about it
but now I've come back to it it's
discolored it's pink it's it's just very
me but it's really about what's on the
back is about these paddles and the
ability to just
or donate what you want your fingers to
do on the underside it's pretty cool and
I have a punch bag for some stupid
reason anyway
coasters on brand coasters ps4 coasters
or Playstation coasters in general yes
I'm that kind of person other things
ibuprofen for all my headaches yes
hardcore I don't talk about my keyboard
it's it's my first ever mechanical
keyboard I usually have the ultra slim
ones but I quite like it
I think it's Logitech but I'm not
bothered oh and this this is the most
important thing in the world
the go XL are you guys who've used my
code that's what I bought with it so
thank you very much for using my code in
fact I need to talk to you about
something else but I'll do that in a bit
okay this is the greatest thing ever so
I've got a peel box now so my lady
friend bought me this so I can open your
parcels and random things you send in
the post with a Batarang if it would
focus so yeah I'll put details somewhere
in this video about my PR box I'd like
you to send stuff to me if you would and
I want to put it in this room I want
this room to represent the community
rather than just some sad guy who sits
on his own a lot hmm didn't sell that
very well other things in the background
yeah I bought this oh gosh that looks
terrible through the viewfinder it tells
me when I have new subs it's a very sad
thing but that's me I've got my retro
tech gab novel book just not so show you
about that very soon and yeah I've got
an obsession with with these Cable Guy
things that hold controllers and this
one of course it's from Borderlands and
I am a backup lumbar yeah obsessed can't
help myself I'm a grown man but I liked
them mmm I've got issues ever night
anyway yeah right let's stop it yeah so
that is something my nephew made me when
he was a child
and I really liked it and these look
like ps1 games but in fact they are
coasters so on the back there are these
little nodule things so you can sit them
on your table so yeah coasters
PlayStation coasters live in the dream
we are my friend it's quite a few Tekken
Tekken 2 Tekken 3
Raisa hey ocarina of time I'm going to
learn to play this this year this is
this is my time this is my instrument
from now on the ocarina more controllers
and smelly for some reason people buy me
these diesel smelly's all the time I
think it's because I stink why else
would you buy someone so many smell he's
an ox oh look anti [ __ ] spray we all
need that this is a good one ok so it's
weird that I've got a bottled water with
nothing in with bought lunch sorry on
well I went to the the Badlands 3-event
over in LA and that thing there in the
big black box is my invitation yes I
know this is weird and what happened was
I put that in my bag to come home and
the American
I don't know border police whatever they
called took up my bag ripped it open
because they thought that was a block of
cocaine move on we have oh by the way I
support Newcastle United if you ever
wondered another cable guy oh yeah ever
thing for Newcastle United then we have
scorpions head from Mortal Kombat 11 and
he's wearing my old favourite headset do
you remember the turtle beach what they
called PS 21px 21 something like that oh
man is so dusty and this thing from when
I got 100,000 subscribers I still
haven't done anything with it it just
sort of sits there in fact I've never
even opened it to be completely honest I
think I looked at it on the first day I
got it and then left it I should do
something with that not to self anyway
other things I have got this psvr helmet
there's the box but it's broken I'm
still keeping it because I'm that sad
and then this thing can you recognize it
the emblem on top this is hitman two
this is how it got to me so one of over
sent this to me and it had hitman two
inside and it's one of the things I
cherish the most I'm going to talk to
you about that in another video though
if you don't mind okay so this is my
entire room doesn't matter about that
bit this is my entire room all this
rubbish I love it so much I've got a
real thing for retro
pick anybody else here like a bit of a
retro consoles retro in general okay so
lots of goodies but then the real the
real magic happens do you recognize this
bad boy the Sega Master System followed
by the Sega Game Gear and then there's a
D s I've never owned a DS I've only just
got that thing and then this is a
Sinclair spectrum plus - that's how old
I am by the way that was my first
console well computer and then we have a
Toshiba MEA MSX sorry and that's where I
played Metal Gear Solid for the first
time those were the days bro those were
the days and this guy here do you
recognize him that's slash from Guns and
Roses looking damn good I have a thing
for him - mm-hmm
I just think he's awesome then we've got
Super Nintendo Nintendo Wii ah you can
see me in the reflection here so I'm
going to take this part of the video out
Adam and and then it's basically all the
handhelds that I've owned over the years
I really like the Vita I really love the
PSP the gameboy advance the gameboy
color there's some damn good good
shizzle going on then there's the minis
there's the ps3 and my son's remote
control and then yeah more just more
history Sega Saturn wow I could never
afford that as a child I now have it
which is pointless so you can make a
drive I think it was called Genesis for
you guys in the USA
yes that's Hacksaw Jim Duggan hiding
behind to play playstation ones other
things timesplitters ps2 on the ps3 look
the original Red Dead and there's the og
ps4 and just more rubbish my room is
full with rubbish dusty rubbish in my
new house I plan on moving by the way
next year I'm going to buy glass
cabinets so I don't have to dust cuz as
you can tell I don't dust other things
in here include all this lots of pop
vinyl figures I have an unhealthy
obsession by the way my favorite is
nemesis damn it he looks good he looks
damn good yeah I start asking people to
buy me these things for Christmas
because it's better than random
rubbish and the quite cheap aren't they
other things more games more games more
Funko pops and then ps4 games with a
random Xbox game on the end because I
bought Borderlands in like so many
versions I had an obsession with for
drugs so yeah that's that's my rubbish
and they say oh this fear is going to be
well the box is actually from
Borderlands 3 but I in hid in here now
is all these stuff I'm going to show you
for Christmas present ideas now holiday
gift ideas from really cheap things to
ridiculously expensive things so yeah my
discard and I are working on that at the
moment okay so on the other side of the
room we have this little bugger do you
recognize him
yet another Borderlands purchase I
couldn't resist is the British gentleman
version though I like the Tash I like
the Hat I like that he actually is
remote-controlled and there's another
wrestler
do you know who that one is I used to
put down here all the different tags
from to go into different events and
this is my hat stand do you recognize
this guy Beethoven handsome guy and
underneath that I've just decided to put
my PC here and yeah it's a good one I
think is a couple of years old I won't
pretend I understand all the technology
of all this sort of stuff but yeah it's
got my capture card in there and there's
a Funko pop - I have a few bright
bombers so one lives in there on my hard
drives lovely so other things includes
there's a picture I haven't put up and
this is my window I shut it so you can't
see where I live and there's something
I'm tough maybe I check the description
there might be a super secret thing for
you to unlock all right I used to play
guitar as well I play a bit still but
not very often and these are packages
that I've got to open which looks like
fun and I'm hoping to get more in future
from you guys maybe maybe and finally I
have a lexer oh my boss so yeah I bought
my own merch is that sad I like it okay
this is my board where I try and tell
myself what to get done this week it
never goes to plan and this number is
important because
last season I said if you use code a
damaru everything I made from that code
I would give back and that's how much I
have left to give back so for me to keep
my word I need to find someone to give
this much money to so hopefully that
doesn't sound seem like some sort of
flex that's not the intention just want
to make sure you know that that is not
my money it's yours so we'll either
bring back streams or I'll give this
away randomly so anyway that was my room
what do you think Harry hill and
hopefully you enjoyed this sorry it's so
rushed anyway thank you very much for
your time it's been an absolute pleasure
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades aka a
British guy who sat in a garage yeah
living the dream garage garage anyway
I'll see you soon
thanks for watching what you appreciate
biggest Baba
[Music]